langage imagé et formules chocs nicolas
sarkozy promet de nettoyer je cite c'est
la courneuve et de débarrasser cette
zone de la banlieue parisienne des
voyous hier au pied de l'une des barres
hlm de la courneuve un enfant de onze
ans a été tué d'une balle le phare
frappant à presque en plein coeur la
police recherche quatre suspects hervé
ghesquière claudine gilbert loïc au pied
de la cité des 4000 à la courneuve
l'effervescence après la mort du petit
sidi ahmed 11 ans et nicolas sarkozy un
ministre de l'intérieur sous les feux
des projecteurs
une fois de plus je vous dis une chose
grèce ceux qui ne respecteront pas la
loi en l'état pas dû
ceux qui veulent s'en sortir on les
aidera fort hier le petit sid-ahmed
hammache a été tué par une balle perdue
en bas de son immeuble
se retrouvant malgré lui au milieu d'une
fusillade le maire de la courneuve
déplore l'insécurité le manque de
policiers dans les quartiers difficiles
et je regrette que de ce point de vue là
n'est pas une action plus résolue des
services de police que j'ai alerté à de
multiples reprises notamment sur ce
quartier de balzac dont on sait que
c'est quelque part un peu une base
arrière du trafic à l'école ou sidi
ahmed étaient scolarisés les enfants et
les enseignants sont sous le choc
il ya beaucoup de peur c'est l'injustice
à sid-ahmed pourquoi lui c'est ils
voient ça comme une injustice puis d'un
autre côté c'est presque leur quotidien
la violence et ça c'est inacceptable
nicolas sarkozy assuré que les auteurs
présumés du meurtre serait retrouvé très
vite il a également réitéré un discours
rôdé celui de la fermeté à tout près les
habitants de la cité des cas puis long
comme les autres habitants de france le
droit à la sécurité
on va donc nettoyé au propre comme au
figuré la cité des 4000 ce soir à la
cité balzac les visages sont dubitatifs
les 1200 habitants du quartier attendent
des actions concrètes
un jeune s'est constitué